The Vancouver police received a call from the BC ambulance service...
...regarding a sudden death in a room on the 21st floor of the Fairmont Pacific Rim Hotel...
...at 1038 Canada Place in downtown Vancouver.
Police attended the room within minutes of the call...
...and paramedics advised the man in the room was clearly deceased.
Coroner staff did attend the scene.
The deceased has been identified as 31-year-old actor Cory Monteith.
That was the Vancouver police at a press conference announcing...
...that they had indeed found "Glee" cast member Cory Monteith dead in his hotel room yesterday.
The 31-year-old is to be transported to the coroner's office...